also wäre ich jetzt 16 wäre wurde zu
gucken da wo ich sein wie thomas bach
bayerischer seite menschen mit scharfen
verstand und die lebensfreude haben und
an eine zukunft denken wenn man die
nicht wählen lassen will
da ist man völlig bekloppt 13 fragen
hier kommt die erste frage brauchen wir
ein wahlrecht ab 16 wenn ihr sagt ja
finde ich eine gute idee dann
positioniert euch bitte auf dem grünen
fällt wenn ihr sagt nee keine so gute
idee dann bitte auf gelb
[Musik]
wo er steht das wissen wir jetzt aber
was meint ihr ist wählen ab 18 so wie es
jetzt ist genau die richtige idee oder
ist es ein bisschen unfair vielleicht
gerade jetzt wo so viele junge menschen
sich politisch engagieren in sachen
klimaschutz in gerechtigkeitsfragen
leute die sagen wir wollen nicht nur mit
reden wir wollen auch mit entscheiden
und zwar nicht erst ab 18 sondern
vielleicht sogar schon ab 16 oder noch
früher oder sagt ihr na ja viele
16-jährige die haben ja vielleicht auch
noch nicht so den überblick
manche schon aber neben nicht alle und
wenn die dann aber alle wählen dürfen
vielleicht keine so gute idee also wo
würdet ihr euch positionieren auf dem
grünen fällt ja mit 16 oder auf dem
gelben lieber so bleiben wie es ist
drei fragen die regeln sind klar wenn er
in einem punkt der gegenseite zustimmt
dann geht gerne einen schritt auf sie zu
und wenn ihr sagt das was du gerade sagt
ist totaler bullshit dann geht gerne
auch ein schritt zurück also mein ziel
ist es ja dass er am ende alle hier im
kompromiss feld landet das wäre
natürlich toll wenn es klappt hier kommt
frage nummer 2 und die geht an friedrich
du bist ja auf deiner seite derjenige
der vielleicht am weitesten von den 16
jahren entfernt ist warum glaubst du
trotzdem ist es eine gute idee wahlrecht
ab 16 einzuführen ja die 16-jährigen
sind sehr gut drauf
die sind sehr stark und sehr schlau und
die kümmern sich einmal mehr um
nachhaltigkeit als die leute in meinem
alter und die kümmern sich auch mehr um
die zukunft weil die haben ja noch einer
und deshalb ist 16 sehr gut wir dürfen
nicht vergessen es gibt entwicklungen
erst durften frauen nicht wählen dann
war 21 erwachsen da war 18 erwachsenen
es könnte 16 erwachsen
und das wird definitiv eine bessere welt
wenn ich sehe was diese umtreibt die
kids auf jeden fall besser als die alten
ihr sagt friedrich die 16-jährigen sind
gut drauf die engagieren sich die machen
viele auch zum beispiel in sachen
klimafragen überzeugt euch dass die
frage ob jemand gut drauf ist oder sich
für politik interessiert zur wahl geht
spielt bei der frage des wahlalters
keine rolle
sonst müssten wir ja eine behörde
einführen die testet ob jemand gut drauf
ist und sich für politik interessiert in
waal führerschein einführen bin ich
strikt dagegen gegenmeinung und da geht
es ja auch mehr als nur reife sondern
auch wirklich ja die politik den
politischen willen den unsere
generationen seit den letzten jahren
immer wieder auf die straße gebracht
habe ich bin mit herzblut für das
wahlalter 16 weil es endlich zeit ist
den 1,5 millionen jungen menschen die
gerade 16 und 17 jahre alt sind ihre
politischen grundrechte zu geben und
natürlich wollen wir auch nicht dass
alle menschen über 18 dann überprüft
werden
aber eigentlich ist es doch so vielen
menschen zu weil eben das wahlalter
nicht an die volljährigkeit geknüpft ist
also so langsam das bin ich das zwar
vielen dank dass du meine argumentation
zustimmt die frage der politischen reife
und des politischen interesses ist kein
kriterium
leo du bist 16 jahre alt du bist
trotzdem nicht für ein wahlrecht für
leute ab 16 das heißt du selbst will ist
kein wahlrecht haben warum nicht ich
würde schon gerne wählen gehen bei der
nächsten bundestagswahl aber es geht ja
nicht nur mich wenn man aber von einer
generation spricht muss man immer die
ganze generation betrachten und klar
freitag hat gezeigt es gibt viele
jugendliche die sich engagieren
das ist aber nur ein teil der generation
ich glaube dass ein wahlrecht ab 16 dazu
führt dass die generation set besonders
die 16 bis 18 jährigen falsch
repräsentiert und dargestellt werden
weil nur ein bestimmtes klientel wählen
gehen würden
das sind die jungen menschen deren
eltern ein hohes einkommen haben einen
überdurchschnittlich hohen bildungsgrad
und meist aus deutschland kommen warum
ist das bei 16 jährigen argument aber
nicht bei 30 jährigen weil ich glaube
dass die politisierung auch später
stattfinden kann also dass viele
vielleicht mit dem ersten job mit dem
ersten gehalt vielleicht irgendwann mit
kindern
ganz anders noch auf die themen schauen
die politisch diskutiert werden
und das eben im alter von 16 leider noch
nicht so oft der fall ist ich sehe
politik und habe ich selbst jede woche
und merkt da einfach auch dass das viele
nicht dazu bringen würde wählen zu gehen
tracy warum gehst du nicht nach vorne ja
ich bin zurück gegangen also ich musste
eigentlich einen schritt vor ein schritt
zurück ich glaube waren und
sozioökonomische gründe die hängen
zusammen
und trotzdem finde ich es nicht richtig
zu sagen dass zum beispiel menschen die
es klassisch benachteiligten haushalten
kommen
migrantische sind automatisch nicht
wegen geben würden ich sehe überhaupt
keinen grund jetzt sich dieses update
für die demokratie einzuführen weil
junge menschen einfach schon in
informell wegen so oft gezeigt haben
dass sie politisch aktiv sind und für
mich ist das wahlrecht ab 16 einen
schritt in die richtige richtung für
eine zukunftsfähige demokratie zum
beispiel bei mir ist es der fall meine
mutter hat noch keinen deutschen pass
ich habe den deutschen pass ich könnte
jetzt wählen gehen und sozusagen
menschen aus migrantischen communities
zu sagen ihr seid persönlich politisch
war die aus diesen haushalten kommt und
ihnen auch nicht die chance zu geben
parteien zu kreieren zum beispiel die
sich genau um diese frage kümmern sich
mega problematischen es geht mir nicht
darum irgend jemanden zu diskriminieren
und auszuschließen es geht mir darum
dass alle teilhaben können und wenn wir
uns die landtagswahlen ankommen es ist
so dass die studien ergeben haben dass
eben privilegiert aber jüngere menschen
eher wählen gehen aber da kann man ja
was aktiv gegen thun mit dem wahlrecht
könnte ihn mir bildungskampagnen
entstehen mit dem wahlrecht könnten
beratungsbüros entstehen die sich genau
um diese zielgruppe kümmern also wenn
wir ein land haben wollen wo demokratie
aktiv gelebt wird und nicht nur von also
eben weiß männlich sozialisiert und so
weiter dann sollten wir uns genau diese
themen anschauen und nicht sagen
das war schon immer ein argument also
diese menschen sind einfach nicht
politisch oder aufgrund ihrer herkunft
aufgrund ihres einkommens werden dieses
wahlrecht wahrnehmen sondern gerade da
ansetzen
das ist auch kein argument die zentrale
frage ist doch warum soll jemand der
nicht die verantwortung für die folgen
seines eigenen handelns trägt die
verantwortung für die gesellschaft
insgesamt mit übernehmen ich bin gegen
den wahlrecht
16 weil ich finde volljährigkeit und
wahlrecht gehören zusammen kann man
nicht entkoppeln jemand der selber die
verantwortung für die folgen seines
eigenen handelns nicht tragen soll nach
auffassung der gesellschaft kann auch
nicht für die gesellschaft insgesamt
entscheiden also du knüpft das wahlrecht
an die volljährigkeit genau warum weil
wir für das petit für das wahlrecht ein
objektives kriterium brauchen
ursprünglich war ja wahlrecht mal
ähnlich wie volljährigkeit 21 jahren mit
der gründung der bundesrepublik das hat
sich mitte der 60er jahre geändert und
damals wurde die wehrpflicht
eingerichtet ins grundgesetz und dann
war das argument wehrpflicht ab 18
dann muss man auch die volljährigkeit
auf 18 absenken und damit das wahlrecht
auch entsprechend absenken
diese argumentation leuchtet mir ein
interessanter weise wird das aber die
absenkung der volljährigkeit nicht
gefordert deine antwort also ich finde
ein bisschen perfide jetzt hier vor da
das zu vermischen weil es eine erst mal
mit dem anderen nichts zu tun hat vor
den demonstrationen vorfreude ist future
hätte niemand über klimapolitik geredet
es gibt verschiedene grenzen von altern
weswegen man mit 16 schon zum beispiel
ausbildung anfang an weswegen man sich
mit 14 führen gott entscheiden kann aber
nicht für die nächsten vier jahre
bundesregierung mit 14 ist man auch
teilweise strafmündig es nicht drei
weise straff warum dann 16
also nach unserem rechtssystem sonst
robert 14 ist mein kind und ab 14
jugendlicher warum vor dass du dann 16
und ich 15 oder 13 oder 12 bei mir war
sogar mit 13 dass ich gegen akw s
demonstriert habe in freiburg und ich
hätte mich mit 13 vielleicht schon für
ein wahlalter entschieden
jetzt ist es aber so dass es schon
kommunalwahlen gibt und teilweise auch
landtagswahl wo man ab 16 wählen dass
das heißt landesregierung haben schon
aktiv gesagt 16 das ist eine politische
reife jetzt kannst du auch wenn warum
das man denn dann in der kommune
entscheiden das geld in iks oder y
gesteckt wird aber man darf nicht
entscheiden wer im nächsten ministerium
für wirtschaft sitzt und die
klimapolitik an die wand fährt ich darf
ganz ich darf ganz kurz was sagen leo
ist gerade auf dich zugegangen und das
ist eigentlich das spannende an dieser
sache warum bist du auf sie zugegangen
weil man gesehen hat junge menschen
können viel bewegen
bei freundes of use
ist immer die frage wie viele waren
wirklich unter 18 also wenn ich in
meiner schulklasse gucke war es nicht so
dass die halbe klasse jeden freitag auf
der straße war und zu den landtagswahlen
möchte ich sagen dass da noch mal ein
unterschied finde ich besteht gerade ich
komme aus bremen das ist nochmal ein
stück regionaler ob vielleicht der eine
spielplatz gebaut wird was mit der
galopprennbahn passiert wollen wieder
eine konzerthalle oder ähnliches da ist
gibt die bundesweite politik noch mal
ein stück weiter entfernt
unglaublich auch weniger interessant für
leute die sich irgendwie nicht
interessieren aber wir reden ja noch ein
bisschen über die die festsetzung eines
alters du sagst dir ist das zu
willkürlich du willst das koppeln an
eine volljährigkeit jetzt hat sie gesagt
na ja wir haben ja mehr oder weniger
willkürliche entscheidungen auch in
anderen fällen 14 hast du gesagt
religions- mündigkeit teilweise
strafmündigkeit das sind ja durchaus
argumente oder aber wenn wir uns die
realitäten anschauen dann sehen wir doch
ganz klar dass es immer mehr davon weg
kommt dass leute mit 16 anfangen
ausbildung zu machen sondern wir haben
eine regelrechte über akademisierung ich
finde dass wir in deutschland einen ganz
sinnvollen zusammenhang aus
staatsbürgerlichen rechten und pflichten
haben und dass jede abweichung von der
volljährigkeit rein willkürlich wäre
gerade bei friends for future seien 90
prozent
ich habe ein abo oder ich strebe ein
diplom doktor oder masterabschluss an
und das zeigt doch dass sich die
ausbildung sich die ausbildungen immer
länger nach hinten verschieben aber auch
die familiengründung
das heißt der zeitpunkt wo ich aktiv
verantwortung für mich aber auch für
andere übernehme verlagert sich nach
hinten im vergleich zu früher
und deshalb verstehe ich es nicht man
dann argumentiert und sagt wir müssen
das wahlalter jetzt vorsetzen
friedrich also ich jetzt 16 wäre wurde
zugucken david orange macht eure scheiße
leid weil das das politischste was die
jungen leute ja auch machen ist ja
kaufen
die kaufen schon besser ein als die
alten die sind weniger fleisch ich kenne
niemanden von den jungen leuten die sich
ein auto besorgen wollen hier in berlin
die die machen ein leben ganz anders
und wenn man die jetzt nicht in das
politische system reinhold dann lebt das
politische system
ganz schön wackelig weil die werden über
kurz oder lang sind die heutigen er
dabei und dann hat das system halt keine
wähler mehr sondern nur um welche
idioten sag ich mal die nicht richtig
gut drauf sind aber menschen mit
scharfen verstand und die lebensfreude
haben und an eine zukunft denken wenn
man die nicht wählen lassen will
da ist man wirklich bekloppt ist richtig
und ein bisschen mal davon wegkommen
dass alle jugendlichen die hier ein auto
fahren wollen mehr und so was also es
gibt da eine ganze breite anwesenden
klar sind viele da bewusst da aber viele
eben auch nicht ich bin immer noch
darauf gespannt wollt ihr die
volljährigkeit auf 16 jahre oder 14 oder
sieben absenken
das heißt die volle verantwortung für
die folgen des eigenen verhaltens deine
antwort nein natürlich nicht weil wir
auch nicht sagen dass volljährigkeit
anderen wahlrecht geknüpft sein ich mal
sagen du siehst dann widerspruch sie
nicht ändern
warum geht warum soll das nicht ab 10 19
jährige so mündig sind aber ich verstehe
das argument auch nicht also ich finde
es ich hätte jetzt nicht so wirklich was
dagegen ehrlich gesagt dass abzusenken
vielleicht ist es auch eine zeitgeist
frage müssen wir uns damit
auseinandersetzen ob junge menschen
heute einfach komplett anders aufwachsen
und vielleicht eben schon viel billiger
sind als wir denken und wenn wenn es um
digitale medien geht sehen wir die die
junge generation hat den erwachsenen so
viel voraus weil sie damit geboren sind
ob sie wollten oder nicht die haben
einfach mehr planen so und das kann eben
in anderen dingen auch passieren wenn
jetzt gerade eine krisensituation so
krass ist das ist dein ganzes aufwachsen
prägt 16 gestern die experten dieser
zeit vielleicht sollten wir die einfach
jetzt mit einbeziehen und unser ganzes
politisches system reformieren
ich halte volljährigkeit für 18 für in
ordnung aber wenn du sagst ich möchte
das wahlrecht auf 16 absenken und die
volljährigkeit dann bist du logisch aber
das war ja eine kompromisslösung musste
mit deinen beiden nachbarn reden warum
sie gegen eine absenkung der
volljährigkeit gemacht es nicht
weiter das ist jede der mögliche
richtige möglicherweise auf den punkt
dass man sagt ich will die beiden beiden
aspekte gar nicht miteinander
kombinieren
noch kurz was du willst du bist beim
alten bleiben
zum torerfolg wirklichkeit ist auch wenn
man realistisch mal jungen menschen
fragt wenn ihr weil wir wollen wir
wählen die volljährigkeit wird mit
runter gesetzt
oder es bleibt alles so wird sich ein
großteil dafür entscheiden dass alles so
bleibt also ich kenne sehr sehr wenig
jugendliche die sagen würden ja ich bin
mit 16 folie sein für alles haften was
ich tue
für alles verantwortlich sein also das
ist glaube ich nicht realistisch wenn
man da die jugend ist gar nicht das
thema was debattiert wird ob die
volljährigkeit herab ich weiß nicht was
die freunde und ich sind dass man doch
davon trainers ich finde es auch krass
zu sagen dass in der kommune zum
beispiel weniger wichtige entscheidungen
getroffen werden
finde ich nicht finde ich das argument
ist mich ein anderes argument ist ja
einer kommune wähle ich ja keine gesetz
ohne wähle ich ja nicht die legislative
ich wähle keine organe die
gesetzgeberisch tätig werden ich wäre
die exekutive
das ist ein massiver unterschied weil
die exekutive aus führt die nächste kein
gesetz zu verändern und die polin stein
fiel ja das ist wie lange das ich will
nur sagen das lässt sich durchaus sehr
logisch begründen warum ich also mit 16
wählen dürfen
und eben auf bundes und landesebene
nicht die irritation warum stefan auf
einmal ganz vorne steht müssen wir uns
auflösen
ja ich stimme dir zu dass es unlogisch
ist dass man kommunalwahlrecht in allen
bundesländern ab 16 hat und es bei
anderen wahl nicht hat warum ist das so
weil es kommunalwahlrecht nicht mit
zweidrittelmehrheit geändert werden muss
sondern mit einfacher mehrheit bei in
allen bundesländern
überall dort wo das wahlrecht an
zweidrittelmehrheit geknüpft ist
im bund und bei fast allen bundesländern
ist das wahlalter auf 18 geblieben mit
halte ich auch für richtig weil
wahlrecht kein spielball von politischen
interessen sein darf und wenn ich dann
noch sein darf so zu tun als seien
kommunalwahlen so ein spielfeld so nicht
so wichtig und da könnte man ja 16
jährige halte ich für eine herabsetzung
von kommunalwahlen als er stand
was glaubst du denn würde sich politisch
ändern wenn jugendliche 16 jährige
wählen dürfen also ich glaube dass
grundsätzlichen umdenken entstehen würde
weil der durchschnitt der
bundestagsabgeordneten ist über 50 jahre
alt also in allen parteien
er würde sie gleich wer sich oder und
der würde sinken wenn 16 jährige wählen
dürfen
aber es könnten mehr menschen sozusagen
gewährt werden
dazu kamen zu diesem jungen menschen 1
18 jährigen direktmandat zb willst doch
das von der politischen haltung abhängig
machen als du wirst auch einen 60
jährigen wählen wenn er seine
politischen ziele unterstützt ja aber
das war nicht wenn eine andere meinung
vertritt dass was mitunter nichts zu
total aber ich glaube dass es schon
wichtig ist zu sehen was wir
lebensrealitäten spiegelten 18-jähriger
bundestagsabgeordneter wieder was ein
50-jähriger uns sehen
es sind so krass viele alte weiße männer
sage ich jetzt einfach mal im bundestag
und meine these ist ich würde eben
menschen wählen die mir auch
entsprechend die mir ein vorbild sind
die hat siemens hat zum beispiel sollen
die politische überzeugung und einander
nein es geht darum dass es menschen gibt
die die lebensrealität der jungen
menschen oder spiegeln und das junge
mensch also dass auch junge kandidaten
zum beispiel die möglichkeit bekommen
wirklich eine zielgruppe zu haben die
sozusagen auf augenhöhe ist ich bin in
deinen worten ein alter weiser mann 65
bis unendlich bauen die junge spaß und
ich behaupte dass meine politische
überzeugung für die ich arbeite mehr für
die junge generation tut als frei disco
future mich würde mal eure meinung
interessieren was glaubt ihr wenn wir
das wahlalter senken gibt es dann einen
schub in richtung mehr perspektive für
jugendliche würden die parteien sich
vielleicht ändern und ihre wahlprogramme
eventuell sogar ändern mehr auf junge
leute zu gehen schreibt sie mir gerne in
die kommentare
und dazu natürlich wie die auch gern mal
wissen von dir sarah du bist ja nun
politisch aktiv würde sich seine partei
vielleicht für die 1,5 millionen
wahlberechtigten die dann dazu kämen
nicht doch ein bisschen ins zeug legen
und sagen hey wie können die nicht ganz
außer acht lassen wir müssen noch weiter
auch an junge leute denken
klingt doch eigentlich logisch ich
erlebe gerade sehr stark auch wie viele
ältere abgeordnete sagen ja vsv future
ist vielleicht nicht gerade die bewegung
die aus dem konservativen spektrum kommt
aber lasst doch mal
die ideen aufnehmen ich habe enkel ich
habe kinder und das spielt ja auch eine
rolle also es ist mitnichten so als wenn
sie sich nur junge menschen einsetzen
könnten für junge interessen und ich
möchte nochmal den punkt herausstellen
dass man sich in parteien engagieren
sollte wenn man mitreden möchte weil die
parteien dafür macht haben und gerade
dadurch für die junge interessen
einsetzen das tue ich seitdem ich jetzt
hin und hat damit gute erfahrung ist
finde ich auch dass halo überzeugend
übrigens du findest du auch überzeugen
aber sehr aber es hat die frage nicht
beantwortet denn ich die frage war ja
würde sich denn nicht zum beispiel die
union dann noch nicht für junge
interessen weil als 50 millionen
wahlberechtigten stimmen
aber ich glaube nicht dass sie aus
reinem opportunismus sagen würde das
nicht speziell junge interessen für die
würden wir uns jetzt mehr einsetzen wenn
wir gute punkt ist du bist nach vorne
gelaufen warum weil der position dass
man natürlich auch in parteien eintreten
kann um sich seiner politischen mut oder
auch seinem engagement irgendwie luft zu
machen
da würde ich dir voll zustimmen aber
trotzdem ich bin zum beispiel jetzt mit
16 dann zur grünen jugend gekommen die
liebend gern hätte ich den nächsten
bundestag mit bestimmt wie liebend gern
hätte ich nicht nur wahlkampf flyer
verteilt sondern auch wirklich meine
partei dann wählen können wir liebten
gern habe ich zwar in den kommunalwahlen
teilgenommen aber für die anderen bayern
hat es nicht gereicht
es sollte doch nicht dabei reichen dass
ich aktionen auf der straße macht dass
ich wirklich für grüne inhalte streiten
aber dann unter 18 noch nicht wählen
darf das macht für mich keinen logischen
schluss so leo kannst du es nach 40 also
spricht er von sich also ich kann das
auch nachvollziehen ich würde gerne
sagen wer nicht wählen gehen will muss
man muss ja nicht geschehen ist naja
aber die voraussetzungen sind ja für
alle menschen unterschiedlicher service
jahr versucht am anfang schon klar zu
machen anders und es wird ja nicht mal
die hälfte der jugendlichen bei den
landtagswahlen immer von diesen ist
zustand aus zu gehen und zu sagen aber
so viele jugendliche wählen jährlich tja
warum tun wir uns dann nicht den arsch
aufreißen das nichts machen weil in der
jugend steckt so viel politische kraft
und die die nicht schon das äußern und
sagen hey wir wollen mit entscheiden die
bremsen wir dann auch noch weil wir dann
auf den rest schauen vielleicht der auf
instagram hängen anstatt zu sagen hey
cool das ist schon macht ihr könnt sie
zum beispiel die anderen inspirieren
weil wir brauchen eure kraft und eure
bedürfnisse eure meinungen
weil wir können gar nicht so denken in
20 jahren sind wir nämlich tot oder in
20 jahren ich hab schon familie ich bin
schon im job ich habe ganz andere
denkstrukturen ganz andere denkt
autobahn mir schon angerichtet und da
finde ich wirklich also ich weiß nicht
ob ihr als junge union den schuss nicht
gehört habe zu sagen ja die junge
wählerschaft es ist jetzt eine gruppe
wie jede andere
das ist deine meinung dass du sagst ja
die älteren setzt sich nicht für die
junge generation eines wegen müssen die
jungen menschen wählen also das thema ja
der welt also ich würde die gesellschaft
der ganzen welt gespalten
ich kann euch aus dem innenleben der
union erzählen ja da heißt es an vielen
stellen was ist in unsere klimapolitik
wir müssen uns positionieren übernehmen
wir das von den grünen oder nicht was
lankreis auf user natürlich käme darauf
einen natürlich haben die vier bewirkt
also ich glaube sehr niedrig was du denn
das hier alles ein gerade also ist das
was hier auch parteipolitisch erzählt
wird in deinem sinne würde ist eine ganz
andere partei gründen wo ich wo stehen
wir denken also ich bin ganz froh dass
ich hier stehe
meine gruppe ist richtig gut aufgestellt
gute leute
ich merke aber auch dass ich gar nicht
so schlau bin ich bin gar nicht so
ausgebildet was das die finessen des
politischen betrifft ich also schauen
mitzubringen
wie viele von unseren zuschauern auch
nicht es sind auch alle kann ich merke
nur dass tatsächlich ich so ein bisschen
denke mensch die 16-jährige die sollen
froh sein dass sie da nicht mitmachen
müssen weil das ist dann komm rüber
anders sieht das ist komplexer die
sollten vielleicht eine neue partei
gründen oder vielleicht sogar zwei neue
parteien grund es ist ja unglaublich was
da eigentlich läuft mit den großen
volksparteien sag ich mal was die sich
zutrauen das ist so wirklich also und
dass man den leuten was trauen sich ja
ja die bescheißen ohne ende
die lügen und betrügen und die müsste
eigentlich alles gefängnis und offenheit
hälfte nicht
ich wollte nur eins sagen ich finde die
jugendlichen die sollten sich jetzt
richtig stark machen und ein eigenes
politisches system gründen bei dem die
anderen wirklich keine rolle mehr
spielen weil die haben es wirklich
versammelt aber so richtig verziehen und
ich denke jetzt gerade in den zeiten der
pandemie hoffen einige die ich so kenne
auf eine große transformation als wäre
das eine chance krise als chance das ist
jetzt eine transformation gibt dass die
welt sich neu gestaltet und dazu finde
ich gehört dass man sagt ja zb 16 16
jährige können wählen das ist ja auch
mal so gewesen dass frauen nicht wählen
durften die durften dann irgendwann
wählen da gab's auch sowie
streitigkeiten dass die eigentlich kein
recht haben dann bergab war mal 21 dann
war 18
jetzt ist vielleicht 16 und es ist ein
prozess in gang kommen und man kann ja
so dankbar sein wenn man an den alten
strukturen noch hängt das tatsächlich
neue leute sich einbringen und besonders
wenn es um am ende die alte struktur zu
halten weil wenn es dann wirklich kein
interesse mehr gibt bei den jungen
leuten und die sagen lasst die machen
wir drehen arsch zu und beschäftigen uns
was ganz anderes
dann sieht es eigentlich noch schlimmer
aus dann nehmen wir doch mal rensmann
weniger komödiantischen argumenten sarah
du bist trotzdem nach hinten gegangen
aber der punkt ist der vielleicht valide
für dich also dass wenn man junge leute
mit 16 schon einbindet und mit
entsprechenden politischen
bildungsmaßnahmen begleitet das man dann
eben vielleicht auch dem entgegen wird
dass diese demokratie den rücken
zudrehen
die realität sieht so aus ich sitz ja im
wahllokal seit ein paar jahren bei den
kommunalwahlen ist schon zwei mal und da
sehe ich ja werden mit 16 bei brecht und
wer geht hin und ich sehe es auch an
über konten statistiken und das ist sind
es einfach nicht die masse auch im
durchschnitt verglichen zu erwachsenen
und das zeigt für mich einfach die leute
bekommen ihre benachrichtigung und sagen
dann schon mal er okay die bahn hat
jetzt in öl anstatt dass ich jetzt aktiv
wählen gehe also ich glaube nicht dass
es das bringt um die menschen mehr zu
politisieren ich frage mal dich an du
bist ja nun eine repräsentantin einer
grünen partei und ist es ja schon
auffällig dass grüne spd fdp meistens
auch und die spd für ein wahlrecht ab 16
sind und cdu und
wenn ich das richtig sehe er dagegen
sind und wir wissen tatsächlich auch
durch umfragen dass mutmaßlich die
parteien die dafür sind auch davon
profitieren würden ist es am ende und
der verdacht den haben ja viele dann
doch nur ein politisches geschacher
darum geht es ja überhaupt nicht uns
geht es darum dass man eben menschen
befähigt an politischen entscheidungen
an entscheidungen der zukunft erteilt zu
haben und nur weil wir jetzt unter
18-jährigen diese entscheidung geben
wird sagen wir nicht hier sich bringt
noch ein brief du sollst für uns stimmt
es geht vor allem darum dass aus diesem
frust der ja auch entstanden ist durch
freiheit ist für future zweieinhalb
jahre drei jahre wurde auf die straße
gegangen und was passiert also des kohle
ausstiegs gesetz ist immer noch 20 38
herzlichen glückwunsch
das bringt uns gar nicht ich finde das
ist zum beispiel sehr weit und du sagst
das reicht noch nicht
dank doch aber das zeigt doch auch dass
wir komplett unterschiedliche
bewertungen des mars bewertungen haben
auch in der sache und man kann deshalb
nicht so festsetzen ja die älteren oder
die politik tut gar nichts nimmt gar
nichts auf oder nimmt alles komplett auf
also ich glaube dass er sehr viel werten
dass auch mit reinspielt dass es auf
keinen fall so pauschal zu sagen ist hab
ich mal sagen warum bist du vorgegangen
das ist wichtig weil es geht um die
werbung um es zu sagen ich verstehe dass
die angst davor da ist gerade wenn man
in der partei ist das dann junge
menschen die eine partei wählen oder die
andere aber eben ich sage ja auch nicht
wahlrecht nur für menschen die die
grünen wählen sondern dem sozusagen in
kauf dass menschen auch parteien wählen
würden die ich vielleicht gar nicht
vertreten und als gegenargument nein
nein was ist wenn man dann
programmatisch wird das finde ich total
blöd aber ich stimme dir zu dass es
unterschiedliche meinungen gibt und ich
würde über eine total donau entscheidung
haben wo ich mir denken werde hoch was
ist denn da passiert aber die kommt von
jungen menschen dann könnte viel mehr
mitgehen stefan also total überzeugt der
in drei schritte nach vorne mit einem
argument stimme ich dir völlig zu die
frage was jemand wählt darf nicht
entscheidend sein bei der frage wie das
wahlrecht entschieden wenn stimme ich
dir völlig zu okay wir sind ja ich muss
aber sagen wir mal kurz zusammenfassen
wir sind es war viel bewegung vor allem
stefan ist viel offener auf seiner
gerade hin und her gedüst aber
tatsächlich habt euch alle ein bisschen
bewegt und es sind relativ viele auch
relativ
weit gekommen und was ich ehrlicherweise
am anfang nicht gedacht hat dass du auch
relativ weit auf ihn zugeht ist habe ich
am anfang nicht so vermutet aber so ist
das in dieser sendung also da stehen wir
jetzt guck ich mal ob ich euch noch
weiter nach vorne bringen kann
wir gehen in die kompromiss runde und
bei der kompromiss mal runter ist es
folgendermaßen ich schlage einen
kompromiss vor
wo ich jetzt glaube nach dieser
diskussion haben wir so einen
minimalkonsens und danach könnt ihr
selber kompromisse vorschlagen und
versuchen die andere seite noch einmal
auf zu euch zu ziehen
also mein kompromiss und das ist jetzt
wirklich einen minimalkonsens also
erstmal ganz unabhängig davon ob das
wahlrecht ab 16 kommt oder nicht wir
wollen ich formuliere jetzt für euch als
gruppe wir wollen dass schüler innen in
der politischen bildung gestärkt werden
zum wohle der demokratie logischerweise
und auch um potenziell wahl
entscheidungen treffen zu können
deswegen soll es in der schule ein
pflichtfach politik geben gerne schon ab
der grundschule stimmt ihr zu dann kommt
ihr bitte nach vorne wenn ihr sagt nur
dass mir zu blöd bleibt stehen oder geht
nach hinten
du findest das nicht ja ich habe ein
problem damit wenn man immer direkt in
den bildungsplan so reich jede partei
bei jeder landtagswahl wenn er in den
bildungsplan ändern also die fdp kommt
mit wirtschaft an
die cdu sagt dann irgendwie ja etwas
oder auch andere parteien wie ist es mit
islamischen religionsunterricht also ich
würde jetzt von der pflicht im
bildungsplan interessant sie das mit zu
pauschal gut du findest
politikunterricht langweilig deswegen
bleibt bestehen
ich finde es eigentlich eine gute idee
aber nicht ab der grundschule also das
braucht man kein witz deswegen halben
schritt folgen aber sonst stimmig zu ich
finde das sollte verpflichtend in allen
schulen ab einem gewissen alter sechste
siebte klasse also wenn momentan de
facto ja nicht so ist
so jetzt merkt ihr euch bitte ganz genau
wo er steht und dann kommt ihr in eurer
gruppe zusammen und überlegt mal ob
ihren kompromiss findet wo ihr sagt dass
stimmen die anderen bestimmt zu die
kommen auf den zyklus
menschen betreffen eine minute zeit für
die beiden gruppen um einen kompromiss
zu finden was wäre denn euer
kompromissen wie würdet ihr gelb und
grün näher zusammenbringen schreibt mir
gerne in die kommentare wer weiß
vielleicht wird's irgendwann
wirklichkeit sind wir soweit wir wissen
noch ungefähr wo er gestanden habe stand
auf der linie genau
doch relativ weit wenn so viel geld habt
ihr einen kompromissvorschlag nicht wir
drei zusammen aber welche drei zusammen
nein
okay was ist ein vorschlag gibt einen
oder zu gibt es zwei ich finde zum
beispiel die kommunalwahlen ab 16 in
ordnung gehen mit der begründung dass
nur die exekutive gewählt wird aber so
ist momentan auch der ist-zustand
deswegen weiß ich nicht ob es ein
richtiger kompromisse aber bei
landtagswahl bist du schon wieder raus
genau weil die eben auch gut zu machen
also das ist ja schon stark also ich
finde man kann bei landtagswahlen ab 16
wählen und ich finde wenn man wirklich
alle versuchen mit einzubeziehen mit
verpflichten im politikunterricht mit
anderen kreativen ideen wie man wirklich
jugendliche von politik begeistern kann
und zum wählen anregen kann man in acht
jahren zum beispiel darüber ernsthaft
sprechen kann ob man das wahlrecht senkt
können wir zur nächsten bundestagswahl
sagen also in fünf jahren
du hast deine teammitglieder vergleich
würdest evaluierungsprozess war das habe
ich das richtig verstanden werden über
nächstenliebe aber wenn man jetzt
startet und das wirklich offensiv angeht
so viele wie möglich einzubinden bleibt
trotzdem steht
ich finds gut mal sehen wir jetzt seid
ihr ein bisschen nach hinten gerutscht
durch den eigenen vorschlag
was habt ihr für den vorschlag dass wir
ein jugendrat auf bundesebene einführen
der zumindest beratend zuerst
hinzugezogen wird damit man sich einen
eindruck machen kann was die jugend denn
will und nicht immer schauen muss was
gibt es da für protest
wenn sondern wirklich auch das
wertschätzt glaube ich auch das
engagement von jungen menschen und
wirklich diese vernetzung hat also der
vorschlag steht im raum
wir gründen einen jugendrat der per
losverfahren zum beispiel bestimmt wird
der bei beschwichtigen politischen
fragen angehört werden muss sofort dafür
[Gelächter]
kompromisse sind immer nur kompromisse
kann ich noch so nachteil nachsatz so
funktioniert oder so ähnlich könnte 13
fragen funktionieren herzlichen dank ihr
seid jetzt hier vorne fast alle
angekommen ich freue mich vielen dank
fürs mitmachen und wenn ihr noch einen
vorschlag habt dann bitte schreibt
einfach rein hätte euch das überzeugt
würde mich jetzt auch mal interessieren
jugendrat per losverfahren es kann also
sein dass du bald mit angela merkel im
kanzleramt sitzen sagt so nicht frau
merkel
vielen vielen dank dass man 13 fragen
ich finde es sollte zwei neue parteien
geben damit die jungen leute auch wieder
was neues zu tun gingen als eine sollte
heißen rosa und so ähnlich wie die
grünen die sich sehr für pflanzen und
tiere eingesetzt haben und so gut dass
jetzt alle parteien darüber reden und du
solltest rosa sich für menschen
einsetzen also wellness gesundheit auch
psychische gesundheit und alles dass der
mensch richtig gut gedeiht und wächst
und alt wird und schildes das macht die
rosa partei und dann gibt es eine partei
die heißen die ersten vertikal ist das
ist eine partei die hat rausgekriegt das
ist eigentlich nie um rechts links oder
mitte geht sondern immer nur um oben und
unten und dass es da auch
missverständnisse gibt und diese partei
kümmert sich darum
und er hat die jungen leute was wohl so
sagen ja das ist neu dass nämlich die
partei muss ja auch gewählt werden ich
glaube daran wenn die jungen leute das
müsste schon so sagen dass die jungen
leute gelegt ist es mögen also ich
glaube dass uns allen klar ist dass wir
vor allem bei der bildung ansetzen
müssen beim
interesse dass wir für alle jugendlichen
genug interesse schaffen um wählen zu
gehen
ja ich glaube dass es unheimlich wichtig
ist dass die diskussion nicht nur hier
bleibt sondern wie gesagt dass in
schulen getragen wird und vor allem dass
wir ja hier heute auch schon politik
zusammen gemacht haben gestritten haben
versucht haben am ende auch teilweise
aufeinander zuzugehen also ich glaube
wir sehen uns in einem ähnlich wir
spitzen beide gerne zu ja und weil nur
wenn man seine meinung auch ziemlich
klare sache ja auch ein kompromiss
finden
und wir haben uns gekappt wir haben
gerade drüber geredet also ich fühle
mich jetzt nicht reduziert auf alter
weiser mann also alt fühle ich mich
sowieso nicht weiß bin ich nur mal man
kann ich eigentlich bestreiten aber das
ist nicht mein leben total und mit
solchen klischees kann ich nichts
anfangen ich glaube dass dieser begriff
kommt oft verletzten drüber und ich
glaube dass es nur wichtig ist für mich
gerade zum beispiel mit meiner
lebensgeschichte da gar nicht so viel
rein zu interpretieren sondern
anzuerkennen dass es verschiedene
perspektiven gibt und trotzdem kann man
im austausch sein und ich glaube es muss
mehr auszog passieren weil gerade solche
debatten finden glaube ich ein selten
statt und auch dass man sich vor treffen
kann und nicht dass man im streit
auseinander geht sondern zum beispiel
dass du hörst dass es mir ein ganz
tolles anliegen was ist eine möglichkeit
was ist eine neue form was ist ein
update für die demokratie mit der du
leben könnte ist also für ein toll wenn
wir die diskussion fortsetzen können
jetzt bin ich aus bonn und du bist in
berlin und corona und so weiter aber wir
können noch direkt vereinbaren in den
nächsten tagen machen eine zu
diskussionen ja und dann gehen wir mal
auf die inhalte nicht nur auf formalia
bis wahlrecht sondern dann redet man
darüber wie ist das mit kohle ausstieg
wie ist das in der politik und in sofern
ihr könnt euch dann wieder dazu schalten
wenn er wollte was ja klar ist wenn das
schiff das wir demokratie nennen nicht
untergehen soll
dann müssen sich mehr menschen und auch
mehr junge menschen politisch
interessiert und auch engagieren
und da bin ich ganz froh da herrschte in
dieser runde eine große einigkeit wenn
euch unser format 13 fragen gefällt dann
könnt ihr hier unseren kanal abonnieren
hier oben gibt es eine weitere folge 13
fragen und hier findet ihr ein weiteres
video zum thema